hi okay this is working great welcome to
my presentation about accessible
customizable select my name is Martin
your cha or you can call me macho
whichever you like and I work as a
front-end developer for the system that
sees at a Czech company now let me
address the elephant in the room why
another JavaScript select after all
isn't it the first rule of Eric's
accessibility that we should always use
the native select whenever possible true
however the native thought is very hard
to style using CSS this forces us to
create our own custom implementations
and we need to re-implement the
accessibility into it as well and I'm
not talking just about high enough
contrast and large enough funds what I
mean is supporting properly assistive
technologies such as the screen readers
used by visually impaired and since this
is obviously a hard problem there must
be plenty of existing solutions that are
out there well I have looked into them I
have reviewed and tested various
existing solutions provided by various
companies also various techniques that
are recommended to anyone needs to
implement their own select element
unfortunately there were some issues for
example the implementation provided by
Google as part of the polymer project is
not compatible with jaws and this quirky
when used with voice-over screen readers
so how can we use such a solution
we cannot on the other hand there's
implementation by jQuery UI which is
buggy with plenty of screen readers and
remains completely silent when used with
voiceover so how can we use such a
solution we cannot to make things worse
we were actually looking for a solution
that could be integrated into any
project regardless of its front-end
technology but of course accessibility
was the top
one priority and what do I mean we were
looking for a solution that works
regardless of the operating system the
user may be using with slide reservation
so when it comes to Linux since it's a
port for assistive technologies it's not
as great as it could be next we of
course must support all the common
commonly used browsers including
Internet Explorer 11 though it is
favorable if the technologies used by
the solution would be poly fillable for
up to i8 as hinted before support for
all major screen readers are used around
the world is a must and of course we
cannot you cannot forget about the
myriad of keyboard shortcuts that are
supported by the native select element
don't worry we don't have to consider
all of these combinations of all these
technologies equally since there are
some combinations that are recommended
by the providers and vendors of these
assistive technologies it doesn't mean
we can ignore the rest we just need to
make sure that these work really well on
the other hand there are some
combinations that are just not
compatible at all for example the jaws
screen reader is incompatible with the
edge browser I'm told this is being
fixed anyway all of this has took us on
a several months of a journey in which
we were testing and prototyping and we
made quite a couple of findings for
example the accessibility support in
browsers could still be improved and
support for Aria which is used to make
our websites more accessible and is
implemented by the assistive
technologies not the browser's is
implemented inconsistently
this leads to situations where you are
prototyping and testing a solution it
seems to work fine in one which one
assistive technology then you start
testing it with another and things
completely break apart after a moment
you'll begin to feel like Alice in the
Wonderland things just don't make
since this is me right here anyway there
are some positive sites about this for
example once you put accessibility into
the mix the Android and iOS platform are
pretty much the same this simplifies
things throughout all of this I've been
reminded of a quote by Steve Jobs yes
he's had more handsome than me great
things are never done by one person in
business they are done by a team of
people similarly to achieve great
accessibility we cannot rely on just a
single technique we will need to find a
combination of techniques that will work
well together well have we find found
such a solution I'm happy to tell you
that indeed we have a we were able to
design a solution that adapts and works
very well with all the compatible
combinations of these major technologies
the project itself is MIT licensed
open-source available at github where
you will find a more detailed project
information a current documentation and
how you may integrate this into any of
your projects regardless of the
technology you may be using thank you
and I wish you and I stay here in
Iceland
you